en 2007 j'ai poignardé mon meilleur ami
à onze reprises pour et série de pour
essayer de lui sauver la vie
si j'avais voulu sauver des vies
j'aurais étudiants d'autres choses je
serais devenue infirmière chirurgienne
dentiste peut être certainement pas de
déshonneur d'expérience utilisateur
multi plateformes
le mauvais design ça tue pourtant les
compagnies les clients les designers et
les développeurs ne sont pas conscients
des conséquences de leur mauvaise
décision
à l'école de design
on nous apprend à faire le mieux
possible à des années le bon et
l'exceptionnel tous les designers
souhaitent des années participer à la
conception d'un objet qui doit être
mémorable tous les designers auraient
voulu travailler sur le iphone
après l'université on prend nos
meilleurs projets les plus beaux et plus
merveilleux on les met dans un portfolio
puis tous les mauvais projets de
l'université on remet ça dans un petit
dossier qu'on cache ordinateur
heureusement ces projets là bas est
oublié vous être pardonné et aucun
utilisateur vont avoir besoin de vivre
avec les conséquences de nos très
mauvaises décisions prises pendant
l'université
malheureusement les professeurs nous
apprennent pas qu'en tant que designer
on a un grand pouvoir sur comment les
technologies vont se développer dans le
futur
et comme dirait mon grand ami ce domaine
un grand pouvoir implique de grandes
responsabilités
la plupart des des anars ont peur que
s'ils font pas du bon design ils vont
faire du design qui est laid mais j'ai
pour mon dire que du design glay pas si
grave que ça quand on regarde le top 50
des sites de commerce électronique en
ligne les plus populaires bains sont pas
toutes les
donc la laideur n'est pas si grave que
ça on devrait jamais avoir peur
d'innover de créer de nouvelles choses
de nouveaux standards de parts que ça
devienne les beaucoup d'autres choses à
prendre en considération autre que la
laideur par exemple le design peut être
hostile pour parler de ce traité j'ai
besoin d'une part un petit peu de la
ford ans la ford ans c'est ce qu'une
forme dirait si on pouvait parler par
exemple cette forme dirait qu'elle est
un triangle et cette forme dirait
qu'elle est très tendre jusque là entre
autres si magiquement on arrondit les
coins ronds rectangle et on rajoute une
emporté ça devient bouton le rectangle
la forme 10 soudainement avec moi pas
besoin d'avoir d'instruction pour savoir
quoi faire avec un bouton
car les règles de la force dans son son
suivi les instructions sont utiles les
jeux vidéo c'est tout de la ford ans
quand jouer à mario
on savait qu'on pouvait sauter sur la
tortue par cas la balle dos rond on
n'allait pas mort et et quand c'est bien
fait on n'a pas besoin d'instructions la
preuve qu'ici a déjà joué à mario opère
les gens qui ont la main levée les
slaves et qui que déjà lu les
instructions mario ah c'est ça en fait
premièrement il ya en abyme la plupart
des gens qui ne savaient pas et si vous
l'avez lu vous auriez appris par exemple
que goumba est un champignon qui a trahi
le royaume du champignon et que c'est
littéralement et que koopa troopa la
tortue est un soldat de l'an pire des
tortues dont le seul but est d'être
d'anéantir mario remplir des tortues le
royaume des champignons d'enfants qu'on
s'éloigne un petit peu mais la forme
dans ça existe vraiment au delà de
l'univers digital la même façon qu'on
sait qu'il fallait pas toucher à ce mini
parce que oui le set est finie ce truc
là on sait qu'il faut pas du cher
hérisson ou à quoi que ce soit qui ait
un pic lhérisson viennent pas avec des
manuels d'instruction
la forme du récent est porteuse de sens
même les chatons qui ne savent pas lire
même si elle est d instruction savent
qu'il faut pas le toucher
je
sa chance est ce que vous dormir y ait
sur ce banc ou n'importe lequel de ses
balades entre je sais que moi je
dormirai pas forcément là mais c'est pas
un problème parce que moi j'ai un lit
chaud qui l'attend tous les soirs à la
maison
ces bancs ont été conçus spécifiquement
pour en restreindre l'accès à un classe
de la population qui voudrait le dormeur
lorsqu'en designer utiliser sa
connaissance de la ford ans pour
restreint quel type de personne a le
droit d'utiliser un objet ça s'appelle
du design hostile sur le web ça existe
aussi
sauf que sur le web on appelle ça des
astuces hostile les astuces aussi long
pour but de vous faire faire certaines
choses que vous aurez pas fait
actuellement par exemple acheter une
assurance sans que vous en rendez compte
ou encore vous inscrire une folle être
que vous n'êtes pas du tout intéressés à
recevoir
voici un exemple je vais vous
l'expliquer pas besoin de lire ici la
compagnie veut nous faire adhérer à sion
l'infolettre donc dans le premier
paragraphe vous demande de cliquer de
cocher les cases des communications que
vous ne souhaitez pas recevoir et dans
le deuxième paragraphe il faut laisser
les cases vides si vous voulez pour les
recevoir
si vous êtes mélanger c'est normal j'ai
fait je leur liste de trois fois avant
pour l'expliquer ça a été conçue ça a
été développé ça a été des années un
designer derrière ce qui est fort
brillant mais lui le des années
spécifiquement pour vous mélangez c'est
astucieux sont refusés partout sur
internet
ils profitent des limitations de notre
cerveau voici un autre exemple n 10 est
une compagnie américaine sur lesquels on
peut commander une personne qui va venir
faire le ménage à la maison et ça c'est
un fait récurrent donc à chaque semaine
ce soir c'est très facile d'aller sur le
site et se créer un compte
ça va super vite ça se fait en deux
temps trois mouvements
mais après si on veut annuler notre
compte on peut pas le faire sur internet
en fait faut appeler au service aux
clients
pour trouver numéro du service clientèle
qui est pas là non plus et en cours
rendent au téléphone la personne à
l'essai nous devons le plein d'affaires
les gens sont pas contents les gens
chialent sur internet c'est vraiment un
très mauvais des années d'expérience
utilisateur
mais le design hostile
bon c'est pas super on s'entend mais
c'est pas le perdre le design ça peut
aussi être cruel par exemple l'an passé
facebook a lancé une application qui
s'appelait rétrospective de votre année
je sais pas si nous en souvenons que
vous l'avez tous et donc pour augmenter
l'engagement facebook fait c'est que
créer une rétrospective automatiquement
avec les photos qui étaient les plus
populaires dans votre fils pendant
l'année ce qui ont oublié de faire c'est
de penser que ce poteau manque y avait
eu des belles années pour des gens qui
avaient vécu le deuil des pertes
importantes où la maladie s'est vraiment
rappelle cruel de leur année voici ce à
quoi ton l'année ont l'air que
l'application dit avec la photo de ta
fille qui est décédée entourée de gens
qui dansent avec des ballons ou encore
de ton appartement qui est en flandre
dernièrement j'ai une collègue que une
expérience vraiment cruel avec la
technologie alors qu'il faisait l'appel
le plus important de sa vie sur festin
son appel a été coupée par un message
d'erreur et elle n'a plus jamais été
capable de parler avec la personne
est ce que vous vous souvenez quand
facetime ont été annoncés par rapport je
me souviens la publicité c'est tout des
gens heureux qu envoyer des messages
heureux à d'autres personnes qui elles
aussi sont toujours heureuse
non
on pense quoi cette plaie
tu vois là
il s'est excusé
avec damas
chaque jour plus de monde se connecte
face à face sur l'iphone
de quoi relancer scénario si les
émotions tu es vraiment intense où ces
gens étaient stressés par exemple prenez
un moment ce moment pour penser à
l'appel le plus important de votre vie
est-ce que c'était une entrevue
téléphonique super importante à l'appel
de votre heures qui viennent accoucher
une dernière discussion avec un avec un
proche dans votre famille ou peut-être
la peine avec un de vos enfants qui ont
besoin d'aidé maintenant imaginer que
cet appel est coupé par un message
d'erreur indisponible pour facepalm
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
est ce qu'il ya un problème avec le
téléphone avec la connexion internet
avec le réseau est ce que vous qu'elle
change apparemment être dans mon
téléphone que je restais je ne sais pas
l'utilisateur y est pris de son côté du
téléphone et il ya aucune ressource pour
l'aider c'est dans des moments comme ça
que je me dise sol ça c'est du design je
suis persuadé les designers les
développeurs qui travaillent sur fait
stable et ont d'excellentes intentions
mais contrairement à ce qu'on pense
c'est pas des superhéros
même s'ils travaillent dans une grande
compagnie qui ont été choisis aussi font
des erreurs on et prennent de mauvaises
décisions fois temps en temps mettre des
intéressés même parce que le père pascal
dessaint un centre situé en 2007 j'ai
passé trois mois à voyager avec mon ami
fred en amérique centrale
on était parti avec notre sac à dos et
on voulait découvrir le monde donc on
est à la quête d'aventuré on s'arrêtait
au guatemala pour rester dans l'auberge
la plus aventureuse et la moins chère il
fallait faire 15 minutes de bateau donc
c'est une très belle très belle auberge
donc le lendemain matin mon ami
commandes des céréales comme d'habitude
les mange et on a pris très rapidement
que les serial y avait des noirs vous
avez sûrement deviné
amy était évidemment allergiques aux
noix près allergiques roma heureusement
voyager tout le temps avec son double
injecteurs mais ce qu'on sait pas ce que
quand une réaction a beaucoup progressé
les mains comment ça se passait dans mon
âme était pas capable de s'injecter lui
même
il m'a donné l'injecteur pour que je le
fasse à sa place ce que j'ai fait j'ai
donné la première injection paix une
injection c'est bon pour les îlots
on est à 15 minutes en bateau dix
minutes plus tard sur le bateau qui bat
on en route pour la clinique
j'essaie de donner la deuxième injection
ça fonctionne pas imaginez un peu la
scène sur un bateau à moteur
il va très très très très vite il ventre
je les cheveux qu'il prête dans visage
il ya deux tours et sur le bateau qui
sont avec nous qu'ils ne comprennent pas
du tout ce qui se passe qui crypte qui
plante le conducteur de bateau qui écrit
des choses en espagnol lent que je ne
maîtrise pas du tout à ce moment là puis
mon ami qui respire fort mais qui
demande à les touristes dû prendre la
main pour la garder ouverte
j'essaie de pas paniqué et je suis pas
je me mets à lire les instructions quand
quelque chose de ta ford à bhl dont on
n'a pas besoin d'instructions mais quand
quelque chose n'allait pas il faut se
résoudre les instructions temps roulé
sur le tube c'est un morceau de papier
qui prenait l'autre qui est écrit en
tout petit et j'arrive à l'étape 9
glisser le collet orange du piston je me
souviens combien j'étais fâché contre
moi même ne pas être capable de
comprendre qu'est-ce qui est en train de
me dire de faire j'ai paniqué je suis un
poignard du monde en soi puis la onzième
fois avec la seringue
je sais pas par quelle magie mais le
fameux col est orange a brisé et puis ça
va fonctionner
je le répète si j'avais voulu sauver des
vies je serais devenue infirmière
chirurgienne certainement pas des anars
ça c'est ce que je pensais à dents
heureusement fred aujourd'hui encore mon
ami ça va très bien mais ça n'a pu
vraiment vraiment mal tourné à cause
d'une très mauvaise décision de design
je sais maintenant parce que j'allais
sur youtube pour aller apprendre comment
ça se passait puis tout ce que j'avais à
faire et ça mais je trouvais pas
peut-être parce que les industries des
instructions disait que c'était orange
et non peut joindre
peut-être parce que c'était l'étape
numéro 9 sur un manuel esque
d'instruction écrit en tout petit sur un
papier enroulé alors que j'étais dans un
bateau qu'elle évite qu'il y avait des
gens qui me parlait en même temps dans
une langue que je comprenais pas
peut-être que je sais juste beaucoup
trop paniquer pour incapable de suivre
des instructions
le rôle du designer salaires rien à voir
avec la beauté le rôle du designer c'est
d'écrire des messages d'instruction
c'est s'assurer que les étapes sont
compréhensibles
c'est aussi s'assurer que quand
développe au design un objet un logiciel
quoi que ce soit on teste dans toutes
les situations
heureusement plusieurs designers le font
très très bien joe diop je montrais
trois exemples de très bons dézingue le
premier facebook qui fait de la nouvelle
application de contrôles d'absence de
danger la semaine passée pour ceux qui
ont pas vu pendant les attentats paris
facebook a lancé cette application là et
ça permettait aux gens qui étaient dans
la zone dangereuse d'indiquer s'il était
hors de danger
alors amis et leur famille imaginez le
nombre de personnes de panique que ça
l'a désamorcée
deuxième exemple si vous cherchez le mot
tristesse sur l'outil de blogs tumblr
le premier résultat va être plutôt des
ressources contre la dépression tom
bleus enfin paris et prend le pari qui
est acceptable d'allonger la tâche de
tous ses utilisateurs à condition de
sauver la vie d'une seule personne
troisième exemple j'aime faire écouter
un petit test
le système d'alarmé de mon bureau
donc ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
quand ils ont installé le nouveau
système d'alarmé on a reçu un courrier a
expliqué qu'il y avait deux types de
l'homme qui pouvait sonner qui indiquait
qu' on doit se préparer à quitter
l'établissement
la deuxième dit qu'on doit quitter
immédiatement ce n'est pas un test
il faut évacuer les lieux donc on va
faire un petit test à main levée je vais
faire jouer le sont et ce qu'ils pensent
que vous devriez évacuer le bâtiment
immédiatement levé la main les autres
gardez votre main ferme donc est-ce que
ça c'est très très urgent ou pauvres
gens vous êtes mort
le design sonore c'est aussi le travail
du designer
voici un exemple d'un bon système
dollars ça c'est le laisse protect qui a
été développée qu'on a acheté qui
fonctionne très bien et c'est un système
d'armes qui a ça dit ceci est une alarme
je détecte du monoxyde de carbone et 10
dans comparaison du halal oxyde de
carbone
rendez-vous le plus près possible d'une
fenêtre s'adoucit ou qui détecte la
fumée
si c'est celui dans la cuisine ça veut
dire il ya de la fumée dans la cuisine
l'eau partie intéressante aussi c'est
qu'on peut le désamorcer en faisant de
bail
pas besoin de sortie tout le monde a des
souvenirs de d'horreur avec les
serviettes
le problème c'est qu'on doit sortir la
serviette et tout et tout aux stands
assez rapidement on enlève les batteries
et on a pu détecteurs de fumée la
plupart des morts dans les incendies au
québec c'est d'en déployer qui n'ont pas
de détecteur de fumée ces trois exemples
la technologie sont très bonnes parce
que les désaccords ont pensé à leur
utilisateur premièrement comme étant des
êtres humains qui ont un spectre
d'émotions
il s'agit donc de design responsable
les ingénieurs reçoivent une bague lors
de la cérémonie de graduation nature et
petit doigt est ce que vous connaissez
l'histoire derrière cette bague la faute
sur koné ok tout voilà qu'on ait eu
pendant la construction du pont québec
il s'est effondré
ça l'a tué 75 personnes l'effondrement
est dû à une erreur de jugement de
l'ingénieur qui s'occupait de des années
la structure du pont le mend veut que
les premières vagues étaient faites à
partir de matériaux pris directement
dans les débris du temps la bague
servait donc de rappel de ceux de
symbole d'humilité et c'est un rappel
aussi constant que les ingénieurs ont
une responsabilité face à la société
mais les ingénieurs sont pas les seuls à
avoir cette responsabilité là les
designers et tous les autres nombre de
des professions ont cette même
responsabilité
ma question pour vous ce soir c'est vous
ce serait quoi votre bague
qu'est-ce qu'il va vous rappeler que
vous avez une responsabilité face à la
société
merci